hold on today well that's it I don't
want to see this move
I switch here
same
even with my own strength make sure that
doesn't move okay
you stronger man
do not walk
with this water your Escape
walk in that mid part of your stick
because that's where you don't have more
power the farther I go up
no matter how hard he is hold the neck
it's not going to work
now he's down here to this logo he's
doing
okay
[Music]
I'm not going to hit one to ten all the
way through and because I will be moving
around
he doesn't have to do this guy instead
of this diamond expecting is just a
drill to help you build knowing which
position you need to be when you do a
number one so when he does number one I
need to be in this position
okay now how I get to this position
there are many different ways
okay I have to figure out a way
to be there when he's icing with the
world with me I need to read it
I should be the one feeding my apartment
he's wearing a helmet because if he
doesn't walk far away
he's gonna get paid so what I do one
you'd be okay too
now three his elbow is what I want to
hit
four four
is what we're doing
it